Also erstmal
wahnsinnig vielen riesen dank für die tollen themenvorschläge der jetzt vor allen dingen auf sap macht ich bin total begeistert aber
Da gibt es auch sachen von
Verschwörungstheoretikern die mehr thesen verkaufen wollen die einfach komplett daneben sind und ich will jetzt mal klartext sprechen
Was ich davon halte also herzlich willkommen bei pixum science fiction klartext?
Ja ihr habt vielleicht mitbekommen dass ich da eigentlich eine ziemlich klare einstellung zu habe was ist die verschwörungstheorie was ist eine
Theorie was ist eine
Hypothese denn das ist ganz wichtig zu wissen und was mir da an verschwörungstheorien wirklich um die ohren fliegt
das kennt manchmal wirklich keine grenzen also wenn jemand behauptet die erde sei flach dann gibt es so viele beweise
Ich meine nur warum gibt es keine flach jupiter riana und so weiter und so fort ihnen maskat letztlich nach dem club der flach marsianer
Gefragt die gibt es nicht weil alles andere um
Uns herum sind kugeln und die erde eben auch warum sollte es anders sein
und klimawandel genau das gleiche da geben und die runden drei prozent die nur co2 von menschen dazu gemacht werden aber das leider jedes jahr
Und deshalb haben wir fast 50 prozent mehr co2 in der atmosphäre als vor der industriellen revolution
Und so weiter und so fort all diese theorie diese verschwörungstheorien
auf youtube videos und das macht mich wirklich, mal
Wo einfach wirklich quatsch drin erzählt wird das hängt mit lügen an und es wird so getan als wäre das in irgendeiner weise
wissenschaftlich oder sonst was die fakten werden durcheinander gewirbelt und
Zusammen geknetet und ich möchte euch eine kleine geschichte aus meiner schule erzählen die mich dazu gebracht hat
Alles mal in meinem kopf hier oben in meinem gehirn das ist super zusatzgerät was wir hier oben haben alles einmal durch
zu durchdenken bevor ich jemand etwas glaube und das war
Im geschichtsunterricht wir hatten wir einen ganz tollen lehrer das war ironie
Also, er war nicht ganz toll sondern, er wollte uns erklären warum kein einziger arbeiter. Im dritten reich die
nsdap gewählt hätte
hintergrund war er war mitglied der
der deutschen kommunistischen partei dkp und die hatten offensichtlich
Weisung von ihrer partei die schüler in den deutschen schulen wenn sie die möglichkeit hatten so zu indoktrinieren
Das konnte natürlich nicht stimmen da braucht man sich nur ein bisschen die
Die die wahl zahlen die wahlanalysen anzugucken und schon kann man drauf und das was dieser mann
Behauptet stimmt ich habe ja gemacht hat er hat sich unser geschichtsbuch genommen hat in der quelle dort
Genommen hat gesagt da steht da drin und dann hat er eine eigene quelle rausgekramt hat gesagt guck
Mal da steht das gegenteil drin also stimmt meine quelle und diese quelle nicht in diesem moment haben wir als schulklasse
angefangen zu arbeiten wir haben selber recherchiert wir haben selber unser zusatzgerät eingeschaltet nicht vergessen und haben herausgefunden
ausdehnen und den
objektiven faktischen gründen kann das nicht stimmen was ist weiter passiert
es gab einen elternabend und am schluss musste dieser lehrer vor die schulklasse treten und sich in aller form entschuldigen
seitdem weiß, ich erstens den unterschied zwischen der
Verschwörungstheorie zwischen einer theorie und einer hypothese nur noch mal ihr habt vielleicht das video von niedriger ist eis nie auf dem kanal gesehen
Da können das noch einmal nachhören wieso eine wissenschaftliche theorie funktioniert dann eine theorie in der wissenschaft zum beispiel die
Evolutionstheorie ist nicht nur bloß eine theorie sondern sie ist bewiesen anders die theorie der dunklen materie und der dunklen energie
Sie ist nicht bewiesen es gibt tausend indizien es ist eine
hypothese und dass die sonne kalt ist die erde flach ist und dem mond einer raumstation iss das sind nicht nur
Keine theorien sondern sind einfach komplett absurde
ideen die schon bereits widerlegt sind für dieses unglaublich viele beweise geben gibt dass sie nicht stimmen also meine bitte an euch
Wenn ihr youtube video sieht guckt euch die von wirklich seriösen kanälen an de abonniert bitte alles was euch
So einen quatsch erzählen will es ist quatsch es sind lügen und es ist einfach unwissen das verbreitet wird und es gibt nichts schlimmeres
Wir haben dafür ein bildungssystem es gibt nichts schlimmeres als um bildung bildung es waren sich wichtig lasst euch also bilden seit
Intelligent werdet schlaue durch bildung und lasst euch nicht in die irre. Führen ja und das beste mittel natürlich
Um schlau zu werden schlau zu bleiben und andere vielleicht auch noch
zu machen ist natürlich hier klickst der wissenschafts kanal zumindest wird dieses themengebiet
Dh wenn er immer die videos vorab, zu diesem thema, zu vielen anderen themen haben wollt dann
abonniert mich hier oder folgt mir hier auf whatsapp da kriegt er
Einen kontakt zu mir könnten wir dann themen vorschlagen ihr könnt andere vorschläge machen es ist der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken
Und ansonsten verlinke ich hier jetzt mal
Ein video wo ich mal dampf abgelassen haben das mache ich auch gerne wenn ich nicht unbedingt klartext rede also bis dann
bleibt dran